oh
so those would be the other things that
will be going on
which is why there's a lot going on
which is why i'm asking
if people can sort of decide if there
are particular things they're interested
in to work on
to help manage the workload
that will not be much between now and
august but will be significant
starting and part of that workload will
be public hearings
part of what you were provided was the
public hearing schedule that occurred 10
and a timeline
in regards to the public hearings those
occurred in
october 10 years ago
it would seem that public hearings
before the data release don't make much
sense
and it would appear to me that public
hearings
immediately after the data release
probably don't make much sense
so october was a month that was selected
approximately 10 years ago
um so you were aware the process and i
would like committee input on this i
don't the process
last year was the public hearings
occurred in the county
and not all committee members attended
them
what generally happened was there was
someone designated to
chair the public hearing in the county
and two other at least two other members
of the committee attended
so there were three committee members
present
at public hearings if not more what
you look i'm thinking it was five but
maybe i just attended once but there
were five
i i went through the minutes and maybe
it was five i don't
recall so my my other recollection was
that a lot of those were simply
listening to people
talk about what they wanted in a
district and we did not have
the data at that point and i know that
people felt that that was particularly
unhelpful
both from our point of view and from
their point of view actually that's sort
of interesting because i read
all the minutes from the public hearing
and i didn't actually see that comment
it
and you know the data will be available
and there are
programs out there that you can get that
i'm sure people will be getting to put
the data in
to have specific suggestions during
public hearings but public hearings
are public hearings so
in the first instance it would seem to
me that the process of having a public
hearing in the county
probably makes sense representative
smith
thank you thank you very much madam
chair um i wonder if some of the
confusion
that has come up in the past is the
public
thinking that those hearings will
provide an opportunity for them to know
what we plan to do and react to that
as if there were a bill that they're
reacting to rather than their
initiating comments to help educate us
about what they would like
and um and you know that's a significant
difference
uh and uh in
point of how we communicate what our
goals are for those hearings we might
help
i've just been notified that sound is on
so apparently if you are listening to
the meeting which i'm assuming is live
streaming
if it has been live streaming at all it
has been live streaming without audio we
had some technical difficulties here
at the meeting this was noticed as a
work session so we were able to proceed
with our discussion here and if you're
listening welcome
to our meeting this is the house special
committee on redistricting it is
june 29th and our apologies for the
delay
i can assure you that the i.t department
here at the state house was in this room
earlier this morning making sure
everything worked and of course it did
not when we went to start the meeting
so thank you for your patience if you're
joining us now
senator smith sorry for that
interruption no i'm
i'm i'm delighted to hear that but there
will be minutes
long of this meeting so that there were
people who were interested
but there will be minutes of the general
discussion that occurred there will not
be transcriptions of minutes for these
meetings right
thank you representative mcguire thank
you madam chair
i was going to suggest that at public
hearings
we ought to have one or maybe two maps
that are at least close to as
suggestions
because most people won't be able to
give you coherent comments without
something to look at
if you have say these you know these two
maps
they both are are close they're not
final
but tell us what the problems or the
good points are we'd be able to get much
more useful feedback
and one would hope with the technology
that we have
since the program has already been
developed that once we get the numbers
in we can do that initial
as representative smith said sort of
this is where we would be
as as the maps are today and
highlight the districts that no longer
work
and maybe that might be a good starting
place because we all can understand what
our current district is
pretty easily the other thing is that in
in many cases
you have a part of a county where you
have
two choices i mean i live in one and
there there's a town that's less than
one rep so it has to be joined and it
could be joined with either of two towns
which would give you a different pattern
but there's pluses and minuses to both
plants
and so we it would be useful to give the
public the choice or at least the
information to say
we have these two plants do you prefer
the one with the larger floaterial or
the spore
the smaller full material which is why i
decided on
the way to go but it's that's the sort
of thing people can look at
and understand a lot better than just
general comments thank you
representative
thank you i was wondering also um having
looked in the very initial stages of mr
anderson's program
last time around before it vanished and
we were not allowed to look at it
anymore
it was a wonderfully user-friendly
program
and i am wondering once the actual
census data gets put into the program
and before that it's not useful at all
i'm wondering if a version of that might
be
made available to the public through our
website so that public members can play
around with it just as
just as folks here could
thank you representative weber that uh
issue has come up in discussions just so
you know
but the discussions on that need to
continue there are copyright issues in
regards to the program
there are issues in regards to making
that kind of
uh programming available to people
and how it is
controlled and whether or not
the program itself could be altered if
it was
on a different platform which would make
the apparent generation of results not
consistent with the underlying
mathematical formula that
the program the original program had so
we have a number of issues that we're
discussing to try and
work things out i am aware that there
was all access
for committee members to the program
for some for a brief time or something
very brief okay
it was a very brief time and then and
then there was no further
access but it seems to me that um my
recollection was that at the time the
copyright belonged to the house and
therefore it
it would be up to the house as to um
how and under what circumstances it was
made available and
you certainly don't have to have the
public tied in
with the official version that's being
used for the official maps but
it might be something that would be very
helpful for people to be able to
get a feel for the kinds of issues we're
dealing with because
for many people it's it's easy to say
gee you know i want my town and the town
next to be together for good and
sufficient reasons
but it is not instantly apparent to them
that two towns over where representative
mcguire lives there's an issue where
there's a town that has to be attached
to one of two towns and there are no
other possibilities so
you know being able to get that feel
might be helpful for the public so i i
just would urge
um those discussions go on with an eye
to providing the maximum access possible
thanks
thank you madam chair um so it's
software so copyright doesn't matter
what we're talking about
is the license agreement so for example
you can own a copy of software
and still not be allowed to modify it
you can own a copy of software and not
be allowed to distribute it
um so those are the things that we're
going to negotiate
in the license agreement and it would be
irresponsible me to say what the outcome
of that will be the intent though
is you all get it as many people as
possible get it one of the
considerations
is how would the public get it
if we put it on the general court
website
which isn't always state-of-the-art uh
what happens if
20 000 people log in today and try to
download software
so i don't know if that will be possible
maybe there's some other way to
distribute it but that is our intent
and and what we're working on um i also
think
we should point out that we're having a
lot of discussions about when things
will happen
the one thing that's for sure you
mentioned working backwards from a
deadline
that date is november 18th that's when
we will complete our work
so i kind of want that in everyone's
minds
without a suspension of the rules um the
deadline for all committees to report
retained bills which these are
so keeping that in mind
in working backwards the public hearing
schedule needs to be before november
after data when there's some information
available
so it really will sort of limit it
probably to the end of september
and data release is mid-august
representative
thank you despite our experience today
with live streaming and zoom
i guess i would like to explore uh
having the county meetings accessible by
zoom
for whatever because we have the
technology
it doesn't always work perfectly but we
have that technology and i think it
would give
more people the opportunity to
participate
at least and even if we can't make it
interactive at least they can
view it uh live stream and get a better
sense and i think the more transparency
we have it's hard for people to get to
meetings so
anyway that's what i would ask that we
consider
thank you that that is being considered
but the issue is also being considered
as to whether or not you can even
provide
those things in a consistent manner for
from county to county
the technology necessary to do it and
do you have public hearings that provide
a different platform in one
county to another there are lots of
issues but we appreciate that there has
been
electronic access in the past the other
issue
there's a difference obviously between
live streaming and any interaction
and i appreciate the clarification on
your part as to at least having it
available to
to look at being as compared to
participation
representative smith thank you thank you
very much
madam chair i know the goal is
november 18th and i also know
that sometimes in the fullness of time
it is not possible to act
responsibly carefully thoroughly
and follow a particular time
deadline and
i would hope that
as we have done on many occasions for
bills less significant than these
but still early enough for us to be able
to meet
all the other responsibilities thank you
as you're aware from my previous
comments the ability to waive the
deadlines as to a request has already
been discussed
um i always do better when there's a
hard deadline though and i think that
november 18th makes the most sense
um because at a certain point once the
data is out
decisions have to be made and to we'll
we'll see where it goes but
i think keeping november 18th as a goal
is is not a bad one though
i know certainly that the committee 10
years ago was meeting
i believe the last two weeks in december
so representative i guess i'm just a
little bit confused
i i thought that we were not likely to
get the
numbers from the cities until march or
something like that and so how are we
going to
what what could possibly lead you to be
confused
how are we how are we finishing the work
in november if we don't understand that
you don't see clearly how we're going to
get all this done
yeah part of the problem representative
will
uh thank you madam chair i it seems like
there's some consensus here that
having public hearings in each county
makes sense that we should be really
committed to that
seems like there's some questions on
whether or not we'll be able to provide
public access via zoom or allow people
to testify remotely
i don't know that there's a lot of
confusion about that i don't expect
that's probably going to happen
okay i'm wondering if similar to the
state budget
and and testifying on the state budget
uh
if we might be able to provide one or
two
evenings where the public can zoom in
to provide their perspective on
how these maps are going to be drawn um
i don't anticipate that um we can
certainly discuss it but that would need
to be approved by the speaker's
office in regards to the process and i
will tell you that
um while i appreciate public comment and
we want as much
public participation as possible having
run
some fairly large hearings both
electronically
and in person i have concerns about
being able to allocate
the appropriate time to new hampshire
residents
in regards to their concerns and the
ability to
monitor that on an electronic platform
i think we've seen massive interests in
this
much different than 10 years ago and i
think for the committee our timeline
and the work we need to figure out what
the best way
is to provide our representatives and
the house the input of the people we
represent
so that's the concern just follow up uh
thanks for taking my question
i'm i'm wondering if we can explore ways
to limit
uh public participation to new hampshire
residents because i agree with you i
share that concern
that would be impossible because anybody
could say they lived anywhere
and it's really easy to do i mean that's
just the reality and
i'd like to think that people wouldn't
do that but i need to tell you that
there might be other people in this room
that have some experience with the fact
that people
would do that and i meant that not for
my profession
not from being a legislator i meant that
from being a lawyer so
representative smith thanks i think
we're skipping a step
and it's kind of funny because this is
the context the conversation's happening
at remember there is one representative
for
roughly every 3 300 people in the state
i would hope that whether they're on the
committee or not
all members of the house would be
talking to their constituents about it
and they have a direct line to this
committee right because
your colleagues will contact you and say
look here's what a majority
of my constituents said i feel like
when we have this there's how many of us
are there
15 15 and we're trying to prioritize how
to get the whole state to talk to these
15 people
that that's not what the new hampshire
house is about
i plan on holding meetings in a couple
of my towns so they're easy to get to to
talk to people about this
you know and the question is what's not
working for you and
what is and i will bring that
information back to the committee
and i think that if we all did that
people wouldn't have to go very far to
go to a meeting and they have access to
us right now they can email us there's a
phone number that they can call
the contents of those phone calls will
be logged and documented
i i think we're pretty accessible so
if people aren't thinking that
a lot of the work is not going to happen
in this room that we're all going to log
a lot of miles talking to people
that maybe that's what we ought to get
our heads around all right um i i didn't
mean that to sound as scolding as it
came out i'm hearing my tone and my
voice and i apologize for that
that's that's all right and i you know i
need to clarify representative smith's
comments on the phone call um there will
be access
on line i am not i i'm not sure that's
accurate um representative weather
i just wanted to clarify that same point
because if somebody is thinking that
phone calls made to my house are
are logged and documented in any kind of
way that's available to the public
other than the envelope that i scribbled
the note on
while i was cooking dinner and threw
into a file somewhere
our our process is is a little more
informal than almost anywhere else in
i was thinking of what representative
smith said and i know that
i have at least one old home day to
present to my constituent i wonder if it
would be possible to get county level
maps
so that we can draw the lines and show
people what the issues are
um i would think counties would have
that um we can check on that though for
you that mean like the one on the
on the state website that just shows the
all right if you want to email those
kind of requests into me and then i can
copy staff and we can see what we can
get you
that's all right we'll take that you
could have just said oh
your question's been answered i would
have felt great that we took care of
something representative weber as as a
follow-up
to representative mcguire's suggestion i
think having
house level maps that show the current
districts and the current floaterial
districts available would be very
helpful
there is such a map i've got one but
it's
but but the county is all you really
well i i think the issue is we'll work
on putting a link to those maps on the
website
um and then people can go to them and if
you're holding an event you can then
log on to it right then and there and
that might eliminate the issue of having
to get back to people in regards to
specific events
and that's part of the reason why we
have cam sitting here so
she can help me remember to get those
requests into it
to link to the website
except that we need need to have
something like a pdf because
i know my old home days don't have
anything like internet connectivity
okay all right so we're gonna need
printouts
all right the last two remaining things
given the current status
i don't know that it makes sense for us
to have a meeting before
august i want your feedback on that i'm
going to be working with representative
bergeron
and i'm as i said hopefully a couple of
others of you in regards to the city
processes so we know exactly where they
are
and maybe getting that nailed down
before the data comes out in august
there will be meetings that will occur
with the senate in regards to nailing
down the process
so i am thinking that august probably is
when it makes sense to meet again and
the question will become whether we meet
before
the 16th or afterwards and it might make
sense to me before the 16th
because by then the details of how
things are going to occur
like you've asked us to hopefully will
have nailed down
and in the meantime if you can send
emails to myself
we can try to get responses out i want
to know whether any committee member
due to meeting in july as compared to
august and that way you can all plan for
representative madam chair do you have a
sense of the frequency
uh of our meetings in august i'm just
wondering if we might be able to
develop some sort of a calendar i
understand that i've been asked to do a
calendar representative turcotte didn't
have enough time
to adjust his schedule um we'll try to
figure that out but
frankly i don't really know how we're
going to be using the program
yet so until i get that figured out i i
mean we don't want to meet and not
have anything and i need to figure out
some communication for
whether or not we're going to have a
group a work session in regards to the
electronics of the map and how we're
going to do that
the county meetings are going to be you
know time for people and i'm mindful of
that
so i am going to try and do a schedule
for meetings but
at this point i don't know exactly how
much the meeting how
often we'll be meeting because that's
somewhat dependent on the division with
the senate
representative weber i'm having a hard
time understanding the utility of having
a meeting before
the data comes out
it would seem to me that it would be
much more useful to have a meeting
subsequent to the data coming out later
in august
well it see the reason i say before
august is that i'm hoping by then people
will have some feedback from
constituents or old home days
so that when we come back for a meeting
in august i don't want to be having a
meeting in august with the data out
without having maps and
i don't want to do maps
unless we've had some input into what
the committee expects to see
because so i don't maybe we have two
meetings then
and i viewed the meeting before
the data release as being a preamble to
what you wanted to see
after the data was released we can meet
after august
if the committee consensus is what we
want to see is as representative smith
said
the map with the current districts
with the deviation calculations as they
would exist if the
districts stayed exactly the same to
give us a base point for going forward
that would be the map that you would see
if i may follow up yeah i i'm still
unclear of the purpose of a meeting
before the data is out because it seems
to me that then
all we have is anecdotal
information of i spoke to somebody
at a town hall meeting and they're
concerned about this or that
but we can do that just as easily after
the data's come out
and and having the
preferences without the data available
seems to me that we're putting a lot of
work in in a direction that we may not
be able
to go in because the numbers aren't
there
to do it that way okay thank you for
your input we'll
make a decision representative smith hi
resident monkey wrench thrower um there
might be value for one meeting we nail
down the software get the user license
worked out and agree this is what we're
going to do
without the data in there representative
weber attendance will not be required
if we decide to have a meeting thank you
yeah
we can use the old data to learn how to
use the software
that's what i talked about in regards to
getting a map so we see where the
deviations are because i don't know if
any of you have had the same experience
i've had
i've had another number of reps come up
to me and say
and that you will find when you do a lot
of your research on district trying um
is what you find is what drives a lot of
what ends up being the product is people
who are in there
keeping things the same for them
so that's been sort of entertaining for
me to see who's come up has anybody else
had that happen
yeah i've had someone say please
change all right i have
one more thing i'd like to do before we
end this meeting does anybody else have
any other business
all right um pam could you come up here
come on up for those of you who don't
know this woman that i am asking to
come up here her name is cam smarlett
she has
been the roots of the tree
that are all things election for how
long
32 years 32 years so when we talk about
having somebody 10 years ago
20 years ago when you're the chair of a
committee or process
this is the woman that really is the
person to whom
you're looking um i'm taking it a little
personally that she's retiring during my
term as chair of election law and chair
of the redistricting commission
and i will note that we referred to joel
who actually used to be in the same
office
and he retired last year so
this is clearly a conspiracy on staff in
regards to
all things election because i suspect
we're going to be
contracting them both for services over
the next year
i think the truth of the matter is is
with covid you will note that the fourth
floor has been blocked to access for
legislators
and staff and joel and pam's
shared the office that was right by the
staircase
where all the legislators were going up
and down
all day long like bunnies hopping up and
down
and asking questions they were the first
line that people got
and i think after a year of not having
us up there
she wanted out because i heard they're
going to let the elevator go to the
fourth force
so so um i had a chance to speak to
david cody
a former chair of the election law
committee and i know this is not the
election law but
has been involved in an election and
redistricting things
and also to representative hozel from
raymond
who is a prior chair and uh
they along with myself uh wish you
the best in your retirement um you have
been
a support like none other for this
committee and i will tell you
among chairs we all say we have the best
committee researcher and assistant but
for
election law it was really true we did
have the best
so i have these flowers for you i
contacted
anta to try to find out what you were
going to do with yourself in your
retirement and
and i suspect it's just go far far away
so um i have this for you
along with a card you only have a desk
for another 24 hours
which
well i'm glad to get the sound up for
this video
just in time for the important part
thank you so much for the recognition
don't take it personally please do you
have any special plans or are you
i'm really trying to find out if she's
going to be around the next few months
travel is in the future but no
no near specific plans other than july
so we'll see well enjoy it you've
certainly earned it and thank you again
all right thank you thank you
thank you all right does anybody have
any other business to come before the
committee
this morning i'm not seeing any so thank
you very much uh
representative i'm just wondering if
there's an opportunity for public
comment today or
no it's a work session thank you very
much everybody